what is the most beautiful idea you've
learned about artificial intelligence
knowledge reasoning
from working on psych for 37 years or
maybe
what is the most beautiful
idea surprising idea about psych to you
when i look up at the stars i kind of
want like that amazement you feel
that wow
and you are part of creating one of the
greatest
one of the most fascinating efforts in
artificial intelligence history so which
element brings you personally joy
this may sound contradictory but i
i think it's
the feeling that
this will be the only time in history
that anyone ever has to teach a computer
this particular thing that we're now
teaching it
it's it's like
painting
starry night
you only have to do that once or
creating the pieta you only have to do
that once
you know it's not it's not like a it's
not like a singer who has to keep you
know it's not like bruce springsteen
having to to sing his greatest hits over
and over again
at different concerts it's more like
a painter
creating a work of art once and then
that's enough it doesn't have to be
created again and so i really get the
sense of
we're telling the system
things that
it's useful for it to know it's useful
for a computer to know for an ai to know
and if we do our jobs right when we do
our jobs right
no one will ever have to do this again
for this particular piece of knowledge
it's very very exciting yeah i guess
there's a sadness to it too it's like
there's a magic to being a parent and
raising a child and teaching them all
about this world
but you know there's
billions of children right like born or
whatever whatever that number is it's a
large number
number of children and a lot of parents
get to experience that joy of teaching
and
with ai systems
you know
uh
they at least the current constructions
they remember
you know you don't get to experience the
joy of teaching um a machine millions of
times better come work for us before
it's too late then exactly that's a good
that's a good hiring pitch yeah
um yeah it's true but then there's also
you know
it's a project that continues forever in
some sense just like wikipedia yes you
get to a stable base of knowledge but
knowledge grows knowledge evolves
we learn as a huma um
you know as a human species
as science as an organism constantly
grows and evolves and changes and then
empower that with the tools of
artificial intelligence and that's going
to keep growing and growing and growing
and many of the
assertions
that you held previously
may need to be significantly expanded
modified all those kinds of things so it
could be like a living organism versus
uh
the analogy i think we started this
conversation with which is like the
solid ground
the the other
experience that we have with our system
is
when it asks clarifying questions
which
inadvertently turn out to be
emotional to us
so at one point it knew that
these were the
named entities who were authorized to
make
changes to the knowledge base and so on
and it noticed that all of them were
people
except for it
because it was also allowed to and so it
said you know am i a person
and we had to like tell it and very
sadly
no
you're not so the moments like that
where it asks questions that are
unintentionally poignant
uh are
are worth treasuring ah that is powerful
you